i'm kind of nervous because i try to be
very strategic about this
i was like i have to make something that
could be any one of us but i don't know
her intuition's been very strong lately
so in a sense who's behind the curtain
okay okay if i lose then i will cook for
the rest of the week if you get it right
then i'll do dishes for the week i like
that
so these chefs need to include these
three ingredients garlic chili oil and
potatoes
[Music]
for this competition i'm going to be
making a scalloped potato roll so first
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a layer of parmesan over here do
about half i tend to cook grandma style
because i actually did kind of learn how
to cook for my grandma just basically
means you don't measure anything so now
we're gonna get our potatoes and lay
them down into sheets more or less okay
now we're gonna add one more layer of
parmesan
on top oh look at that cheesy goodness
all great flavors require great
sacrifice we're lactose intolerant
pop it in the oven for at 400 degrees
for
20 minutes now we're going to make our
beef mixture with onions tomatoes
parsley paprika salt and of course our
favorite chili oil so now we're going to
add
the onion plenty of onions
add the beef oh that was close
so i always give janna the better
looking plate because sometimes i mess
up and it just does not look good i
don't even question that anymore that's
just the norm all right so now we're
going to throw in everything else first
goes the tomatoes tomato tomato tomato
paprika
a lot of parsley
we'll save some and then for our special
ingredient fried chili oil this old
asian lady has saved our household my
favorite part of this specific one are
the peanuts i like to use a lot of this
because it just tastes good here's one
more little spoon just so that she knows
it's me janna's told me before that i
needed to add more seasoning so ever
since then i make sure i always add
enough seasoning
so now we're going to do our spinach
mixture i'm going to wilt this
melting wilting wilting add the garlic
now this is just to make sure that we
are vampire free today all right now i'm
gonna check on the potatoes let's see
how these look oh
they look like they're coming along
nicely
look at that and crispy and delicious
all right so now we're gonna mix the
spinach with the ricotta this is our
popeyes inspired contribution to this
dish okay now that the spinach is ready
we're going to assemble the roll all
right
oh this beef mixture i don't know how
chefs just do their job in general
because i would want to eat every moment
that i'm cooking because i am hungry
right now let's do one dusting
okay so now we're ready to roll
everything together
there we go oh come on stay together
oh boy casualties oh it's almost there
ah more casualties oh my god this is a
mess
i guess that's it
[Music]
i am going to make a california
breakfast burrito but i'm going to use
filipino tapa instead of bacon i'm
hoping that because of the ingredients
that i picked that will make jana think
it's austin because it's something that
she likes all right let's just get
started so i have my chopped potatoes
i'm gonna mix olive oil garlic powder
and i'm already going to add some chili
oil so it absorbs i remember seeing this
chili oil in janna's instagram story i'm
not sure how spicy she likes it but
chili oil isn't that spicy i'm going to
mix them together so you put it here the
oven is preheated and i'm just gonna put
it there and let it roast so this is
pickled veggies it's specifically
carrots and daikon so this has vinegar
water
sugar and salt so we're gonna put this
aside and let this like
pickle i've said pickles so many times
pickle pickle pickles pickle pickle
pickle pickle can pickle anything and
this is the tapa it's just beef sirloin
that you marinate with soy sauce and
basically like a bunch of like asian
ingredients you can marinate this on
your own but i just got it from the
filipino store i chose this because i
wanted to have a filipino ingredient in
the breakfast burrito because janna's
filipino i'm filipino and austin is also
filipino so it'll really confuse her
oh
it's crackling
all right next up eggs i'm gonna cook
the eggs the way that i saw gordon
ramsay cook it which is like a lot of
butter and can like mixing it all the
time he's just like continuously
whisking it to make it creamy he like he
didn't mix it in the bowl you just
poured it in
and then he mixed it here and then he
would take it off so it doesn't like
burn or something and then you put it
back on and like mix mix mix mix mix i
did not think if this is how austin
makes scrambled eggs
maybe janna will think oh austin learned
something new he really does love me so
it's almost at the consistency that i
want i'm just gonna add the cheese now
i'm gonna check all the potatoes now oh
they look crispy so i'm just kind of
making like an aioli chili oil spread
because it looks nice i'm just gonna
like a sandwich spread i'm gonna add the
potatoes
i decided on carrots and daikon because
that's what they use in bunnies and i
like botami i read that when you wrap a
burrito you like start here right and
then you like do it like this
i think i did
make too much like i put too much stuff
in here but it should be okay and we're
done
[Music]
for this competition i'm making a potato
crusted pizza with fried garlic chips
and a drizzle of chili oil on top not
knowing jana very well i just wanted to
make something that was crazy delicious
and that like you knew it was going to
be good just by looking at it i also
wanted to make sure that you could get
everything in one bite and i think a
slice of pizza is the way to go all
right i'm going to start by making our
potato crust so i've got some shredded
potatoes that i drained really really
well to make them as dry as possible and
we'll go ahead and we're gonna add two
eggs to it as our binder for some
seasoning we're gonna add some garlic
powder we're gonna add some onion powder
salt
and i'm gonna hit it with just a little
bit of black pepper i think for
a little kick in the base and then i'm
just going to mix this together
all right that holds together like
something and i think i'm just going to
this and now i'm going to spend a couple
minutes just trying to build this crust
i mean that looks like a crust to me i'm
gonna pop this into the oven
moving on to our garlic component so i
have very thinly sliced garlic here and
i'm just gonna fry these very quickly so
that we have some crispy delicious
garlic chips and then we're gonna use
that oil to brush the crust of the pizza
when it comes out i'm gonna go sausage
directly into the pan grab this crust
brush this all with this delicious
garlic oil really make sure that garlic
flavor is all over the place then we're
going to top it this is just monterey
jack cheese i wanted to choose something
that was a little bit more neutral it's
not a tradish mozzarella and we'll take
our sausage gonna put this one back into
the oven
let this cheese melt and then we'll top
it with our garlic chips and our chili
oil and we'll have janna taste it and
then the last thing for some color some
scallions i don't know janna but i think
after this we're going to be buds
what what is this wow this smells fancy
is this potato i'm impressed it's really
flavorful i will say so whoever made
this really got the flavors in i don't
know
i don't know if austin is capable of
making it look like this because it's so
fancy but
he could also want to be fancy so that
he could throw me off
well job well done mysterious person
number one is it you austin i can't tell
anyway on to the next one
[Music]
oh what
interesting it's a burrito
it's a breakfast burrito this looks
amazing i love a breakfast burrito
is this
brisket
oh man i feel like this is austin i feel
like this is austin
i don't know if i'm wrong but i don't
know he also wants to trick me
this feels like an austin meal though
because we love breakfast burritos so i
feel like that's his thing
oh it's a pizza i'm assuming this crust
is potato crust oh whoa it is
soft
[Music]
um okay hefty i can tell she's thick
which i appreciate the presentation was
good the potato itself i feel like
isn't seasoned
or not
not like it's not season but i feel like
it's not seasoned enough for me which
makes me think this is awesome but i'm
not married to that because i know how
austin makes his potatoes sometimes not
to say that he doesn't season it it's
just
it i don't know that's what my gut is
telling me but
i'm debating whether i should go with my
intuition or just go against my
intuition but i think i'll go with it i
think this one i think this one was
austin
it has to be i i i refuse i refuse to
cook for the rest of the week oh my god
i'm scared
[Laughter]
yeah
that looks really good this is really
good damn now i don't know maybe austin
is capable of making that first dish
sorry
i'm gonna say that this is cody oh my
god i'm scared
i'm gonna get it no no i will just see
you watching your cats
i'm so sorry there wasn't enough salt i
am sorry
you made this
yeah unbeknownst to your mind
and imagination wait does that mean i
don't have to cook
i guess so okay
[Music]
you